I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
la Llorona the weeping woman of Mexico
varieties of this monster exist in
cultures around the globe and we see in
La Llorona a few common characteristics
she is a ghost and a mother and as well
always we pain because she drowned her
children culturally the story of La
Llorona is used to scare children into
obedience but a ghostly woman in white
sulking in the darkness is hardly
original to understand why la Llorona
looks and acts the way she does and why
she is such a cultural icon in Mexico we
must look to history back to a time of
Spanish conquistadors and Aztec
goddesses la Orana has some truly unique
elements to her story and she represents
the social history of Greater Mexico the
stories of La Llorona fall into two main
groups encuentro the first-person
accounts of people who have seen the
ghost and historia tales of how la
Llorona went from regular woman to
murderer and ghost although her his
story had changes based on where the
story is told and who tells it the
general tale is this once there was a
beautiful indigenous Mexican woman who
fell in love with the man of a higher
social status for a while they lived
happily together raising their children
then one day the man abandons her
sometimes he plans to marry a woman of
his own status
other times he threatens to take the
children rage and despair drived woman
to drown her children and then she meets
her own demise God curses her to wander
as a ghost searching for her lost
children so she can get into heaven she
cries out for them in the night and in
her desperation may kidnap other
children mistaking them for her own most
scholars agree that at least some of the
foundational parts of the story date
well before the 16th century when the
Spanish began their conquests in the
Western Hemisphere
take this goddess for instance known as
the first woman in the world to the
Aztecs she appears dressed in white and
carrying a cradle walking through the
streets at night weeping disappearing
into a lake or river Aztecs placed high
value on women who died in childbirth
they became cultural heroes and they
were the only women who could achieve
afterlife like the male Warriors but
their afterlife wasn't so great they
became night ghosts waiting at the
crossroads to curse children and tempt
men yeah that's a lawyer onna in 16th
century Mexico two key things happened
that shaped lawyer ona into the monster
we recognize today first the Spanish
conquistadors led by Hernan Cortes
arrived and with them came the
introduction of several influences the
first was European mythology an
influential mythological figure was
Medea the Greek enchantress who murders
her own children after being abandoned
by her husband then there was
Christianity which was injected into the
myth adding God in heaven to the story
the other major influence was a woman
known as La Malinche during the conquest
as part of a peace agreement Cortes and
his men were given twenty female slaves
including Malinche a woman born to a
noble family
meline Shaye made the most of a bad
situation immediately becoming
invaluable to the Spanish as a
translator and diplomat she served as
Cortez's personal translator and
ultimately became his mistress and
mother of his son meline chaste son was
legitimized but taken away from her and
sent to Spain for education most
historians agree that with a baleen
chaste presence the expedition and
conquest of Tenochtitlan would never
have happened which obviously makes her
a controversial figure
she has been portrayed as everything
from a traitor to a victim and is
referred to by many names only since the
twentieth century has maligne shape and
accepted more widely as something other
than a traitor and that's around the
same time La Llorona was recognized as a
symbol of resistance to traditional
patriarchy by Chicana authors and others
the parallels between La Llorona and
maligne che are undeniable and they
contributed to one another's folklore
both were abandoned by a wealthy
Spaniard and were indigenous mothers
whose children were taken from them in
these stories the children the
relationships between indigenous women
and European men
and the introduction of a new religion
represent the conflict between
indigenous cultures and incoming
Europeans since then the story of La
Llorona has travelled far and wide and
she is known by many names as her myth
has spread so has her reach in addition
to bodies of water she is now said to
haunt more urban spaces like highways
and railroads she's been known to appear
in the back of your car if you failed to
give her a ride making for what is
possibly the worst backseat driver I've
ever heard of and with the myth becoming
more visible in popular culture I'm sure
more people will hear about her for the
first time La Llorona story is open to a
variety of interpretations it can be a
warning to women to choose their lovers
cautiously or about the difficulty of
being a single mother it can be seen as
a criticism of female sexuality or as a
metaphor for the grief over generations
of indigenous Mexicans killed during the
Spanish conquest personally I'm inclined
to side with those who read La Llorona
as a representation of the painful
merging of Spanish and indigenous
cultures she represents the religious
and social history of Greater Mexico and
continues to do so today
[Music]